[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to one of our favorite
programs here at Secrets until in some
TV and that is I'd like to know my name
is Siri Murray you know and it occurs to
me that there are certain things we all
like to do my wife likes to Garden I'm
not a big Gardener I think Pastor boy
you like to Garden yeah I like the
Garden on the table
that's pretty much where I am I like the
garden when it gets to the table I do
like gardening too yeah give us more
guys and and Pastor Salazar our general
manager of some TV Latino uh you like to
build yes you know that's right um so we
all have things we like to do I'll tell
you what I like to do actually gentlemen
I like to vacuum there's something about
vacuuming my wife says you vacuum too
much but putting on the vacuum and
hearing that that Roar going across the
cabinet floor just it's it's kind of
strange yeah maybe the only you ever
know who likes the vacuum I'm sure that
Irma is happy that you like the vacuum
well she she says actually vacuum too
much
my point being gentlemen is that there
are certain things we like to do and one
of the things I think we universally
like to do is to answer the questions
that come in on this program this is one
of our our favorite uh pastimes and
Enterprises I think we like Sabbath
school also that gives us a chance to to
discuss the word of God and we'd like to
discuss the word of God in concert one
with the other it's it's fun coming
together
answering your questions seeing what's
on your mind in your heart and then
answering those questions from the word
of God and we make you this promise each
and every time we do this program that
when we do answer the questions they
will be from the word of God it's a
little late in the history of this world
to be uh listening to man's opinion you
want to hear a word from the Lord and we
promise that you will hear that word
when you said in the question we will
take our time with them we will not try
to rush through them but we want to give
do deference and due diligence to all of
your questions so that when the question
is answered you've got a good handle on
what the word of God has to say about
that particular issue so we promise you
to do that should you want to get in on
the fun
we ask you we beg you we even platoon
you send your questions into TV at some
TV s-u-m as in Mary
tv.org is on the screen right before you
TV at
summitv.org and we will get to your
questions as soon as we can I know
sometimes there's a little bit of
frustration if a person doesn't hear
that question in one or two weeks that's
because the pile of questions that we
are getting is fairly impressive and
fairly thick so we're working our way
through them they are coming in from all
around the world and we thank God for
that gentlemen amen uh that we are
getting viewership and buy-in from
across the planet and we we invite you
when you send in your question if you'd
let us know where you're coming from uh
the country the region of the world we'd
appreciate that because it gives us an
idea of the viewership and the reach and
the footprint of this particular
Ministry so do that if you will and we
promise we'll get to your questions just
as soon as we can and you hold on we'll
get to them Pastor boy if you would
offer prayer for us we will launch out
we've got one or two questions that uh
were left over from the last program
then we've got another new batch of
questions here that we want to take a
look at let's pray
Father in heaven
we are so thankful that you have given
us your word
in a world that is so confused
you have given us certainty
and answers to our questions
through the written word amen amen we
ask that as we open that word today to
answer these questions that you will
give us wisdom
and that you will give us speech to
speak the truth amen and we also ask
that you will be with those who are
watching this program that they might be
blessed amen and we thank you for the
promise of your presence in Jesus name
we pray amen amen and amen all right we
have one from Kayla or Kyla uh Munoz
and she wants to know she's talking to
us uh here at um I'd like to know
have a couple of questions one at what
point did Eve lose her light
did she lose it immediately or when Adam
sinned and uh we'll look at the second
one also I've heard that if Adam had not
sinned that somehow he could have
redeemed Eve yet I never hear how they
come by this conclusion is this true if
so uh would you please explain sorry
gentlemen uh one when did Eve lose her
light and then two
um
uh
could Adam have uh let's say I have
heard that if Adam had not sinned that
he could have redeemed Eve um so that's
the second question let's look at the
first one first when did when did Eve
lose her life
well I believe that in the Bible and we
go to Genesis 3. uh it sort of gives us
an idea of when that happened
because in verse remember they were
clothed with a light uh the spirit
clears that or makes us very clear but
we know that they were not they were
they were the Bible says that they were
naked but they were not ashamed meaning
they were not revealing their nakedness
something was covering them that's in
verse 25 of chapter two but Chapter 3 of
Genesis and you see that in verse 7
after the husband verse 6 after he ate
of the food it says number seven and the
eyes of them both were opened and they
knew that they were naked and they saw
fake leaves together and made themselves
aprons so we see that the
removing or the vanishing of the light
happened almost simultaneously they both
were at the same time both realized oh
now we are without our clothes and then
they decided so the fact is from the
Bible we can see that she did not lose
by herself the light or the of the
covering and then I think uh we can also
go to spread prophecy and we'll see
there in Chapter 3 of
better than prophets were page 56
that and I'll read this just so that it
can be very clear it says Eve when she
went to give the fruit to Adam says if
was before him as beautiful and
apparently as innocent as before this
act of disobedience
she expressed greater love for him than
before no sign of death appeared in her
and he decided to brave the consequences
he sees the fruit and quickly ate and
this is one way we can see that she did
not lose you know she appeared as
beautiful and as innocent as before so I
don't think you know it really clears
that they did not or she did not lose
the the covering of light her garment
but after Adam actually took take of the
fruit it's significant that in the Bible
Adam is held accountable for introducing
sin into the world not Eve that's right
and uh and that's significant so
apparently she did not lose her covering
of light until Adam sinned and when Adam
sinned they both uh lost their light
right and made themselves coverings uh
the second question is also answered in
this same page
um
and it says she was a part of himself
that is a part of Adam
and he could not endure the thought of
Separation he did not realize that the
same infinite power who had from the
dust of the earth created him a living
beautiful form and had in love given him
a companion could Supply her place
that's right so at least we know that
God could have supplied her place now I
have not been able to find anything
uh in the Bible about whether God would
have redeemed Eve or not the assumption
is that probably he would but how he
would do it when Adam was faithful and
Eve wasn't I think those are questions
we're going to have to ask Jesus when we
when we sit at his feet uh under the
tree of life
unless you guys know of any any source
that I don't know about concerning
whether God is going to redeem Eve or
not yeah there were I I saw nothing
there and and I came across that same
page the tentacles of that understanding
are quite long for those who who don't
believe in male headshifts who don't
believe in God placing a certain
responsibility on the man things were
not finalized the situation was not
deemed unredeemable until Adam sinned
there was still something redeemable
about that situation which is why Eve
had not lost her life yet there was
another solution Adam just couldn't see
his way to that solution he couldn't see
past uh the problem to a God who could
had a solution for that problem and so
he he ate uh and at that point it became
unredeemable they both lost their light
and of course the the set of
circumstances that we now find ourselves
in began at that point in time clearly
Adam was the head of the race yes no
doubt whatsoever because God held him
accountable when you go to Romans
chapter 5 yes it says sin enters the
World by one man yes and death through
sin
so so that is absolutely clear that
there is headship absolutely uh before
sin yeah you know the thing that that
that that that sort of gums up the works
when it comes to headship is the the
the fact that those who are called we
had do such a bad job at it you know
um yeah when when we talk about Christ
and God and Christ allowing himself as
as being inferior to God we think of
subjection we think of of lording it
over we think of slavery think of all
these kinds of synonyms which don't
really fit you know uh if if those who
are called to be head would do a better
job at being head than the idea of
headshot wouldn't be so onerous to
people but it's it's it's it it leaves a
bad taste in your mouth when you think
of the situations that exist on Earth as
it is currently constructed yeah right
headship is not a true bad thing
somebody's got to take the lead uh and
somebody's got to follow and if if if
God the father and God the son decide
together this is how we're going to work
this things out this thing out it's not
a bad thing and it's not a negative
thing if it was a bad thing
then the relationship between the father
and the son would not be a good thing
right because uh we are told clearly in
First Corinthians 11 verse 3 that the
head of Christ is God is God but but the
father loves the son so it's very simple
for the son to subject himself to the
father's Authority voluntarily uh you
know uh in Ephesians chapter 5 verse 22
it says wives submit yourselves to your
own husbands as to the Lord
and then that would be very easy if the
husbands did what verse 25 says husbands
love your wives just as Christ also
loved the church and gave himself for
her so if the husband was loving and
kind and provided for the needs of the
wife and everything the wife would have
no issue with being subject to the
authority of the husband but it's
because husbands have abused their
headship Authority that women have
reacted and said we will not submit yes
amen when I was working on my my uh
doctorate degree I identified
um and named several kinds of authority
one is positional Authority that's like
you are the president of the ministry
that that title president gives you
certain prerogatives sure if you were to
leave and someone else would assume
presidency those progress would pass to
that person because the power is in the
position not necessarily the person
right then there is what I call
different Authority definite Authority
is the authority you give someone uh
because you know they have your best
interests at heart so I feel this way
you feel this way but you've always been
right in the past and I know that when
you make a decision it is for your good
but also for mine so I defer to you I
give you that Authority because you're
going to make the best the best of the
situation right that's different
Authority then there's also referent
Authority
um which means
um I have the power to make a decision
but I will run it by you you know that's
where I'll run it by refer to you just
to get some input from you so that my my
decision is is balanced well in heaven
all of those exist position different
and reference because we know that uh
John 10 30 very simple text I and my
father are one so we think of like we
acted like we move alike so there is no
subjugation in the authority that God
exercises over the sun because they are
at at
their agreed in all that they do uh as
we as respects mankind amen so it's a
good question it's a really uh good good
question all right
um now this is our new batch and this
one is coming from Bulgaria so we got
we've got viewers in Bulgaria this is
Philip dragolov uh from Bulgaria uh
great to hear from you Philip he wants
to know what was the critique of Desmond
Ford against the investigative judgment
and how do you respond to it now that's
a that's we're going back a few years
and you remember during that time you
had a lot of you had Desmond Ford you
had uh on the heels of the brimsmeade
controversy uh you had Walter Ray during
that time you had the Holy Spirit as a
woman controversy I mean the 70s were
really really uh controversial and I
think Desmond Ford because he had so
many students he was teaching uh and
there was there was this whole
generation of pastors who came up under
him and so the tentacles of his
disaffection just went throughout the
church and and sort of stuck with the
church for a long long time and we are
feeling the effects of that even till
today absolutely uh perhaps until that
generation of pastors or terrorism moves
off it will always sort of be with us
but what was his issue as you recall
pastor and uh you were a young
basketball
well we were
the bottom line
of his objection to the investigative
judgment was that it takes away our
Assurance of salvation
that's that's the bottom line because he
believed that when you're Justified uh
by Christ
um it's almost like uh once saved always
saved you're secure because of
justification uh and your Works your
behavior doesn't have anything to do
directly with your salvation you know
sanctification is the result but it
doesn't have anything to do with
justification
and so he said you know if the time
comes when we're going to have to be
before God's judgment bar to render an
account of our works
well then you know if our works don't
measure up uh our Salvation is
threatened so base that's the bottom
line of everybody who criticizes the
investigative judgment right but the
Bible tells us very clearly
that Believers are going to be judged
before the second coming that's right
let's read uh Second Corinthians 5 verse
10.
and let's remember that Paul is writing
to believers
he's writing this to Believers correct
it reads there for we must all appear
before the Judgment seat of Christ
that everyone may receive the things
done in his body according to that he
had done whether it be good or bad so
who is judged everyone
who believes yeah including everybody
because of course that is in the
pre-advant investigative judgment during
the Millennium after the Millennium well
you know we'll participate in the
Judgment during the Millennium and after
the Millennium the wicked will see their
cases but but before the second coming
the Apostle Paul says to the Corinthians
we
Believers Must ALL appear all appear
before the Judgment seat of Christ to
give an account on the things that we
did that's our acts whether they're good
or evil over their evil now why does God
need an investigative judgment before
the second come doesn't he already know
from eternity past who's going to be
saved and who's going to be lost yes now
that's the big question that is asked
well you know Pastor it's it's a reason
of showing transparency to his character
is is a judgment that also will satisfy
not only the
the requirements of the University as a
whole to see that people who believe in
Christ have been found worthy to be him
with him for they have given up their
love of the world their love of sin but
is also to secure you know precisely
that the universe will never fall into
another experience as such as this as a
sin you know that God can deal with the
sin issue remove the sin problem from
the universe but it has to be opened it
has to be transparent it has to be shown
clearly that those that profess to have
Christ to have accepted Jesus are not
only just defied for that believe in him
but have allowed his life to transform
their hearts so it's it's it's a process
it's not just you know just because God
wants to make a judgment but it's really
because it needs to be done for the
purification to the to sanctify his
people through this process of
investigating their lives and I think
that you know the Judgment that you know
that the idea of people going against
the Judgment having a problem with the
Judgment still we say today many many
Adventists uh sadly are really and you
know uncomfortable with that
concept of judgment because they feel
that oh my life is coming before the
Lord I may have something you know that
is not ready I'm not ready I'm not 100
perfect whatever it is and and that that
fear of the judgment is really what
turns them off and they rather not deal
with it or or say that it's wrong but
it's not the case
yeah the bottom line is
that
the Judgment before the second coming is
only of those who ever profess the name
of Christ
and there's a reason for that when Jesus
comes he's going to take the faithful
ones to heaven but before he takes them
to Heaven he has to do the judgment to
show that they are worthy right to enter
Heaven there's no urgency with the
wicked because their cases are going to
be examined later
um
in the church there are good and bad
fish
yes the boat is the church are you
sorted out there's good and bad fish
when they get to the shore in the
parable of Jesus what happens you
separate yes absolutely the good fish
from the bad fish
you have weed and tears when does the
weed and when is the separation of weed
and tears at the End of the Age yes
there's the investigative judgment
in the church there are wise and foolish
virgins do all of them claim to be
followers of Christ sure but is there
are there some that are not really
genuine Believers absolutely sure are
there those who say Lord Lord did we
cast out demons in your name perform
miracles in your name prophesy in your
name Jesus is going to say I never knew
you yet they professed Jesus yes there
are people who have a form of godliness
but don't have the power of God
godliness
so the purpose of the judgment is to
reveal before the universe who Jesus has
a right to take to Heaven that's right
because there are people who appear to
be good
but inside there were problems and the
judgment will show that particular that
heart detail right where the heart is
where the heart was and the actions you
know if they follow along with that
profession because the judgment will
also involve the secret things according
to Ecclesiastes 12 verse 13 and 14 14.
it says even the secret things of the
heart yeah absolutely so it doesn't take
away our Assurance of Salvation as long
as we remain and abide in Christ
if we're not abiding in Christ then you
have a reason to worry but if we're
abiding in Christ we can be sure that
Jesus is going to represent us in the
Judgment as long as we repent and
confess our sins and uh and you know
trust in the merits of Jesus and by the
power of the Holy Spirit overcome we
have nothing to fear in the Judgment
because Jesus is going to be our
Defender absolutely another thing that I
again I'm not 100 familiar with every
you know person that went through this
experience at the time of England Ford's
uh you know height but uh you can see
from the most part those that reject the
concept of the investigative judgment
you can see their lives eventually will
turn against I mean go away from the
Lord they start embracing not just that
false Doctrine but everything else is
rejecting there's a lot of confusion in
the minds of those that don't believe in
in our doctrine of this they get a
judgment and they opposed to it you will
see that their lives fall into bigger
sin and bigger sin and that's kind of
the sad part about it you know it's it's
like you shut down the holy spirit that
impresses your heart that this is
something true that you are to go
through judgment if you profess the name
of Jesus so that's correct you know as
it occurred to me because I I remember
one of the other things that uh one of
the side issues of um doesn't afford is
that when Christ left he went directly
into the most holy uh he didn't there
was no first apart apartment Ministry of
Christ uh so then investigative started
as he left one of the things that occurs
to me and I like what you just said
technically
when Christ comes again everyone every
person who's ever lives case will be
decided
because those who are going to go to
heaven will go to heaven right if if you
don't go
it's because you're not going you know
there's not another another case of
course what we will do later on in First
Corinthians tells us we'll look and see
that everything that God did was fair
that review that review precisely well
said
you know we will see that everything and
those who didn't go shouldn't have gone
that's right and those who did go
should have gone so that we will see
that God is fair and I like the idea of
transparency because you know I believe
God doeth all things well amen but God's
not going to say well we're going to go
with your belief I'm going to show you
you know I'm going to give you the the
chapter and verse of of every person so
that you know that I did things fairly
absolutely the thing that that
encourages me is that God is not trying
to keep us out of Kingdom he's trying to
get us absolutely you know absolutely
and if there's any way he can get us in
short of breaking the law because that
would make Christ's death worthless uh
uh he's going to do it you know he's
going to do it because he loves us he
wants to get us in well so we start with
the books in our favor amen and all we
have to do is stop fighting him and
surrender him and he will save us amen
yeah you know
um how would you feel about going before
a judge
and without any review of The Evidence
the judge says
guilty
yeah what would people say
hmm
who knows whether that person was guilty
or not there was no trial
so there would be questions about the
judge very much so but God's system of
jurisprudence
is the same system that is used in
democratic governments today
first you have a review of The Evidence
the trial so that everybody can see it
secondly based on the investigation of
the evidence you have the sentence or
the verdict
and then the time comes when the verdict
is implemented in actuality right that's
the way that God does he considers us
innocent
until we are proven guilty yes in a
court of law God is not less just
than human beings
God will give his people
their time in court amen he he does the
same process
investigation or trial
the verdict guilty or not guilty
depending on what came forth in the
trial and then
the execution of the sentence and in the
case of the righteous the execution of
the sentence we usually think of
execution in a bad sense of what he's
executed but the execution of the
sentence means implementing the sentence
precisely which uh the dead in Christ
will rise and those who are alive will
be transformed and then they will be
taken for a thousand years to heaven and
then we will do a judgment review yes
why those who were left behind uh were
left behind absolutely uh it's kind of
like uh it's kind of like um
like a instant replay yes you know does
it the instant replay change the play
yeah oh it just shows whether whether
the Umpire got the call right right of
course and so that's what's going to
happen during the Millennium it's kind
of like what in the work of an auditor
that's right you know an audit does
auditor cook the books no no the auditor
of the books as the purpose of seeing if
the records of the books were kept
properly and so with God during the
Thousand Years God isn't going to say
oh wait a minute we should have brought
that guy down there oh my God everything
that God decided will be proven
absolutely amen amen amen well this
happens sometimes sometimes we take one
program to do one question because of
the import of the question we invite you
to keep on writing to keep on watching
our time has fast slipped into eternity
allowed being closing to wish you both
Grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you again
soon bye bye and God bless see you later
thank you
[Music]